m
[Musique]
enquête - conflit qui depuis que j'ai
m'a dit j'ai envie de rire
rien ne peut me retenir et moi j'ai
horreur des gens qui sont pas dues au
sérieux
[Musique]
à
williams encore est bon je sais pas si
vous avez loupé une aide ça parce que je
n'ai pas de temps à perdre - mon humeur
ne te regarde
[Rires]
j'ai autre chose à faire qu'à écouter
plaisanterie je t'ai jamais ils ne
croient pas ils vous croient pas le
pauvre mauvais raconte barre mais le cas
nous valons bien
on va me v13 mon lépi à toi monnaie si
j'en avais un je sentirais tout de même
les vous d'éviter la tête ascaride de
jeu tu me dire ce que tu vois dans mon
bureau
tournez vous s'il vous plaît aux je vois
grand trou à votre habit mais alors
c'est donc free mon habillé trou est
trop bon dieu mais que va dire le grand
yaka
je n'ose pas me présenter devant lui
alors qu elle à faire mais qu'on fait il
proposait une pièce pour boucher les
trous mais comment faire une réparation
par des années passées de secours a pas
de moi ici pour ce pauvre mosca il est
extra gagnent en ridicule où l on
bachand télé mais des avait pavé la baie
de morgat vous mais le coeur donnez moi
du style unique hui est dit ici ça
dépasse mes possibilités soit on fait
chauffer au soleil à hadj habib ben
voilà titillé par étape at on tiré le
gros lot acheté par bobo mais bon ma
fille
je continue à 15 h cup et voilà malgré
lui jeu réservé à ceux toujours très
dangereux pour la fin laissez moi me
concentrer à tabit 103 enfants tchadiens
cup
et voilà je suis désolé voilà alors
c'est complet n'est ce pas est ce que à
ce que bruxelles est satisfait c'est un
petit tissu besoin de toi je commence à
trouver le temps long
pourvu que bérénice ne m'oublie pas
notre cas je suis choqué je vous dise
ainsi l'église s'il te plaît aux enfants
est un drôle de travail pour un lion
dépêche-toi titus ou e membre des
mauvais c et d vont être le vin oui non
c'est maladroit titus facile à dire du
pt l'enfer c'est ton temps froid a
failli et voilà c'est le morceau de
tissu pendant que je coûts compass très
bien ne bouge plus 1.6 après par là a
pas de gauche après droite et c'est
terminé
si je lis statistiques on peut très vite
dès qu'on va il n'y a plus de trous no
mercy mais jamais merci je peux j'allais
voir le grain à la tête tu est
supportable
je rentre chez moi attends je vais te
buter
tant mieux vaut rire tout seul non
préfère ma et après après
et c'est une autre histoire rappelant
magath l'été au pays du jeune a dit
vraiment on vient deux parties de billes
avec le grand yaka les feux
je vous dis pas à vous amuser allez vite
retrouver le grand gâteau vous demande
où est d'en trouver cbi je ferai bien
une partie vous ne peut pas jouer tout
seul
capcom cas
amy est un site à quel sujet il ya an
par une partie billes avec moi j'vois ou
ivoire a non je ne veux pas facile arabe
à mon cas je te propose une partie de
beach est d'abord un show n'est pas le
moment j'ai tu savais chez qui marie
abadie mois se côtoient le plus beau
collier du grand yaka disparu cueillez
splendide je le cherche partout en tout
et pour tout ce qui est bien ou bi-mode
non non non non qui qu il faut que je
retrouve ce que le shisha les personnes
veuves et oubliés avec moi on m'a oublié
melchior il sera sûrement d'accord je
vais lui en parler mais le gars bac
le pôle à aÿ la leaf est en phase permet
pour cause de fermeture aura alors c'est
pas de chance
même quand on n'est pas fini harper vous
pourrez demain de ramasser mais b témoin
des attitudes et regarde j'ai tout est
dit tu vas jouer avec moi elle à
l'entente en habit à moi elles sont dans
mon père est mort ce sommet berlin en
vidant menthe ou t'es pas vous ici alors
on vous si tu gagnes du biscione tétouan
ou au congo dans la balance comme villes
rebelles ont commencé voilà avoue grand
iata le monde et elle était elle est
partie il a été trop fort et dégueulasse
trop fort c'est parce que je suis le
plus fort et elle est encore parti on
voit comme un sac de farine et les bises
auront perdu
je suis le plus fort c'est moi le plus
peur c'est vrai mais ils vont plus loin
que les tiennes je cherchais dans tous
les coins le collier du grand jacques à
est introuvable
quelle affaire
qu'est-ce que chez vous ou par exemple
une perle une des pires halle du collier
du grand yaka c'est bien une perle n'est
ce pas je ne me trompe pas c'est une
perte à lui de chevaux de perles pas une
troisième faire encore des perles
mais doug et rennes chez les pupilles
titus aller de l'avant les siennes ouais
enfin en vol alors c'est trop loin son
père deux tonnes et la dernière et au
plein et les parties j'ai perdu toute ma
vie mais je me suis bien amusé et getti
d'espérer j'ai reconstitué le cahier du
craj ak je vais le lui apporter
vous aviez des costumes de gagner la
partie
l'ebit saura mois on a beaucoup de
bêtises je n'ai qu'une parole tu seras
récompensé botia voilà ce que j'arrive
callas à charlie
alors qu'est ce que tu m'apportes vais
me [ __ ] que six écrans yaka vous
vouliez le m aujourd'hui donner quitus
il a gagné un parti de lui je suis très
content j'ai perdu mais je les subis et
la vision ma mois en empruntant l'a10 et
après après c'est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]
un couteau - quand tu étais aux filles
que j'aime à dire qu'en octobre destinée
ça me rappelle qu'un jour j'ai tellement
près du grand yaka un bon vivant un gros
croissance un peu de lobbying en eau et
l emmental adema pour excuser bois titus
je vient troubler tour où ma femme je
m'en doutais tu vas me dire que le grand
lac à me demande tu es prodigieux titus
tu devines toujours tout en wifi
le grand yaka tu attends un patient pour
l'off mon fémur droit vent ou voix
d'yves et oui je ne s'accompagne pas tu
connais le chemin un homme petit et
c'est bien tard comme bonjour grands
lacs
dis moi qui tu es ce que tu aimes la
peinture aux adore la peinture
surtout la peinture roberta se veut dire
à lui à lui parce que c'est plus les
bons meirieu alors voilà j'ai le cul tu
fait supporter alors ceci cela à logis
et quand tu peux vous de titus et les
titille vit un grand gars je ne je ne je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas
jamais fait de ma vie est l'anti tissus
comme un jury très doucement doucement
il me faut du matériel
demain avant de certaines étapes sont
ainsi traduits et de la tenir
titi qui voit l'arrivée que je veux que
tu me fasses tribaux fait une très
ressemblants coiteux très naturelle
comme comme je suis là 3 qui comptaient
sur moi mais vous soigner à lui
[Musique]
il faut bien mélanger il manque en judo
diderot à à fait parfait prêtons le
vitro avec un jaune capterait meilleur
il est prêt n'est ce pas l'ambitieuse
mayonnaise là qui tue ce qu'est ce que
nous faisons tu commun sur une heure
pays où ce mandat non natale
elle est portée bout vous vous coupez
l'inspiration
voyons voyons voyons visa voron barbe
pointu si le parti n'est né en suisse
bien comme ça si si j'vous ai mal pas
mal mais vous n'êtes pas s'il vous plaît
c'est que je vais être très réussi et
soyez tranquille vous va les fatiguer
vos arguments comment je vois show x
turin sont en train de commettre une
horreur
je ne sais pas tenir un pinceau le grand
yaka vous que je fasse son patron alors
si tu savais ouais ouais très bien
grouillante a très bien être avec vous
en prie aidez moi non je sens qu'il te
feront attention at albi à tabac il voit
là pour aider un appareil de protons il
est bientôt finie titus en un clin
d'oeil c'est instantané
8 mai trois sorties la photographie la
voile et tout s'énerve apathie tous il
faut la déplie heures on dirait qu'il va
parler d'eux a été tué chez toi je veux
voir mon porte et moi vous pouvez venir
le voir
il est terminé merci à 30 ans à eux des
artistes dont le besoin
au revoir pikachu elle a voyagé chez des
vrais débats donne mondiale et tout à
lui
ceci vaut 1 que c'est si beau ah bravo à
je suis magnifique et là je suis ma
fille à titus tué entre grunt artistes
ainsi 6 6 1 6 6 1 vrai mais je suis
content de toi tu es vraiment j'étais
avrillon moi je suis brufau que je suis
bourg vous voyez la peinture à lille m'a
fait pas du tout vim
et après après c'est une autre histoire
[Musique]
écoute moi quand tu es une fille que
j'aime à dire quand j'étais petit
j'étais comme d'oise j'étais très
curieux 3 au curieux
quelle grande armoire j'aimerais bien
savoir que leurs besoins il permet à clé
titus je t'en prie ne touche pas à
chaque arbre
pourquoi d'un terme est bien géré mes
jeux parce que je n'ai pas trouvé la clé
ont la clé il n'y a plus de clés elle
est perdue on ne l'a jamais retrouvée
tout ça bien mystérieuse que c'est sûr
que cette armoire contient trop plein de
coiffure voudrait bien ouvrir garde
sûrement kaka font leur beurre
je n'ai bu que du noir qui me faudrait
aller comme on veut pour vous par mois
sans clé un nouveau leader
[Musique]
rien à part
ils n'emportaient comme outil venir est
bien temps louvre temps moi très bien la
fuite
il est parti j'avais peur que titus
dhabi mme sept à pouvoir en essayant de
l'ouvrir il n'est pas là je suis
tranquille et elle est bien fermé voilà
on est debout titre on finira bien par
l'ouvrir
bon réveillon la barbe de père hongrois
lafarge est tordu laborde beau-père l
armoire toujours permet ben est payant
bien faire des coups encore un autre
café et la moelle tous fermés allons
voyons avec la fille elle est bien
aiguisé je vais faire un grand trou par
l'antenne ne pourrait pas ses côtés qui
perdure à dakar la cep
est monté aussi haut
cet or moi et me restait plus en vue
d'ouvrir son marteau a l'air solide moi
je vais taper taper pour cause de
tourmente
capucine et voilà mon dernier où tu café
et cette armoire tout en me faisant de
la plaie alors que tu fais du collage ou
du bricolage navrant de voir vos rêves
fous que tu réfléchis un peu le marteau
ne cédant qu'un set en finale est une
clé je n'en ferai pas la tête comme moi
mais il se foule de créer un compte sur
moi je suis un véritable porte klein 1 h
abu hadba dévoile la robella dont bobek
sauver la france formaient adjabi donne
pas il faudra alors tonnes poids des
précisions précise quelques lettres
futile
il nous faut la paix de cette armoire
voilà voilà voilà
si je l'avais dit plus tôt je la montre
ou socialement serge munté be le coeur
bleu je suis sûr qu'elle est là c'est la
bonne tu donnes deux tourelles à revoir
son au revoir le goyen cas bâton
[Musique]
vous voyez vous les ouverte où on vient
de voir qu'il ya là dedans
[Musique]
elle est vide entre le mans vise à
redonner tout son monde pour bien pour
vient
et après après est une autre histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
raconte moi quand tu étais au pays de
j'aime à dire eh bien je vais te
raconter l'histoire du petit poisson de
grande yaka nuit je me dis qu'est ce que
[Musique]
parce que je m'ennuie appartement de
petits poissons tu sais tu as un grand
bocal ça m'amuse demandé j'ai cherché
trop croyez que je vais le chercher
[Musique]
par exemple comment il m'a dit moi ça
ouais c'est bien mais chut je le vois
pas chez ce petit il est si petit il a
dû chef chantier et puis mes frites
ziakas et j'ai rompu
il n'a pas dû aller bien loin des phases
où je vais le chercher
[Musique]
non il le bon papa maman d'apprendre à
qui tu as quel faire le petit poisson du
crack un disparu
regarde le bo qualifie d' on m'en parle
de l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas le
temps des bordures les pattes ton pote
et boissons il était là ce matin et il
est ici bien à à mon cher titus mais
aide moi elle retrouvait pourtant sympa
mon staff va le rattraper ton petit
poisson hoyaux pas d'odeur de poissons
et pas deux gouttes d'eau par ici berry
miss bérénice c'est what it is programme
dérange-t-il bonnes questions seulement
tu n'as pas vu par faire un poisson par
là par hasard qui politise tgv après son
entraîneur
et des questions stupides alors ils ont
tous poissons n'est pas parce que tout
seul quelques a dû l'emporter
quelqu'un qui aime le poisson ou d une
idée et non pas que j'ai trouvé
l'armateur de bras font alors notre mère
gord hill nous sommes comme vous avez
des ennuis ya de drôle de bruit lors de
votre sac analystes restent il vous
plait ne me mettrais bien je vais le
québec on est bien content fait naître
même bien vous avez là dedans petit
poisson qui n'est pas ma nous étonner
car notre petit poisson riz à cadrer
voilà un japon qui va servir de bocal
allait mettre nos coeurs pensez vous
videz votre pote jusqu'à la dernière
goutte
ce petit poisson de châteaudun et sa
piste ils n'étaient pas d'amour mais non
belle c'est parce que je le sois titus
alors j'ai vu de l'eau je l'a vu et su
petit poisson était cachée au fond me
direz rien iata mais n'y revenez pas le
plus petit il est parti je ne veux plus
qu'elle ne ferait pas
il pense au titisee tuner tv
oui je vais le prendre là
regardez la bien aimée
mon petit poisson police au feu de bois
je crois bien qu'il était mieux dans
leur est donné ce nom
et après après est une autre histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore que moi quand tu es une fille que
je n'exige une fois je me suis endormi
et j'ai fait un rêve extradables bah
c'est pas pour le grand prix à cannes
pour satisfaire un peu de piquant sur le
comptage à ses impeccables mauvais signe
on est vraiment bien dans le fauteuil du
grand yaka ne pourrait bien petit dodo -
moi si j'étais le gwoka alors n'ya pas
travail et mieux que ça allait plus vite
le grand des douze taureaux encadrés ou
est gentil genève au jour de grand titre
et si tu t'arrêtes tu as d'un coup de
bâton gauche très bien les joueurs un
teaser mais subira ce cas où est la voie
la quantité que désire le grand titus
vannes oc en croissant allez paris j'ai
couru altitude si vous trouvez coincé un
grand titus ou maladroit mais en fait on
me montre aux enfants
tout aura des mules coups de bâton ça si
ça l'a attrapé le mont pardonnez-moi
grand titus je le ferai plus j'ai dit du
même coup des bateaux on merci merci
gratitude merci mais je les ai bien
mérité cette manière
arrivé au pouvoir
mon petit gars car il me fait bien rire
ont été voir arriver la plus belle la
plus belle victoire de la plus de ils
peuvent vous ici marraine bermudes ne
vous en pensez pas si mauvais
l'indiscret de votre solitude interrompt
le secret homogène
vous parlez comme libre voici armée
d'hommes ont marre dont nous parlait
débarrassez vous des batteries portables
les gars vont lui donner un enfant
trouvé un grand artiste est trop grand
pour lui
venez d rémire mon trône où l'attend
installez vous confortablement
je me sens si petit tout près de vous
quand it is on fera rapport de l'ond le
goûter voilà voilà gratitude merci mon
cas à présent à victor appréciant danton
m me dira-t-on grand titus vous êtes le
plus généreux qu'en pensez-vous mazères
belle remise aux quantités se croirait
[Musique]
vtt ou à pied le das il est isolé du
monde kata fonds propres nous grand york
en personne n'a le droit de s'asseoir
sur le trône en place est un grand fan
gang ou encore une pertinents tu auras
divino coup de bâton ceci cela allait
le coup de bâton sam est bien égal j'ai
fait un si beau rêve
et après après c'est une autre histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un contenu acuité au pij de gêne à dire
mon élan d'accord avec moi votre attente
et le départ de burning
[Musique]
où
compact il est donc bernie tu vas te
robe une notice je t'invite assez pour
partir en vacances
tout part en vacances au monde oui oui
je pars dans ces minutes tient
maintenant tout avec mes robes ont droit
comme ça donc au menu et doit descendre
de tracy moment tout se voit son cours
du porc d'enfants et nous c'est vrai
c'est la campagne chez ma cousine tuer
j'en perds tous mes robes et de moi ça
m'a valley rob lendl pas molli tiani pas
si tu es content surtout prendre une
valise
il tend pas le malaise mais moi je ne
sais pas si on a trouvé un outil sa vie
valises à lille à terme à l'ue walden a
rempli des foules avides cuba moi c'est
du moins ce bric à brac à voile comme
temps est parfait regarde vers nous elle
te plaît il est ni sic pour les titres
vu du côté make-up par là qu'il est chez
nous parce qu'un but à ses jeux fable
radio gayak cas et la falaise price au
jeu les bretons sont vivants et ont ils
ont les balcons aux ovins ça scandaleux
selon l'avis de la banalise et ont leurs
porteurs une valise historique avec la
cale je fais trois fois le genre du
monde
on voulait faire une enquête il faut que
jusqu au fret et l'expulsion lorient
attend veulent enfermer et voilà suis
très arty il devra le dire au revoir à
mon sport dans le mur
qui a raison ces pronostics est si
gentil pour nous et avec moi via
sept cochons the baltic banalisant n'est
pas noir le frange nos l'orage ou ce
jardin ma valise et laval à eau pour la
police
je reprends construction de mon bien ben
c'est bien ça a déjà rempli jamais
vinals elle voit la justice et fight ma
valise et aboie monde a été content
quand je vous dis au revoir car titus
les affaires par terre selon lui ils ont
disparu à partir en vacances on va la
retrouver
pourquoi savoir où et voilà que tout est
rangé je ne vais rien non eh bien je
suis content quand sa route
j'ai encore cinq minutes devant joie je
vais dire au revoir à ce cargo ce cas tu
restes ici et là voilà peut-être que
nous tairons évidemment que la valise
d'anelka il en a pas besoin
il a quand même tout mon matériel dans
le rapport cest la voix c'est la balise
vite rempli on l'a un peu trop le temps
presse
une valise comme ça moi j'en connais qui
la voudrait bien failli et elle est
prête à les revoir vous paierez mise les
adieux le plus courts sont les meilleurs
tiens réseau tice on va tenir si vous
coupez la vanille
à voir je t'écrirai ou 1 là où ça valide
après l'envoi la cause et à melchior que
quand v comment vient de m'apprendre
et après après c'est une autre histoire
ne te le rencontrer comme nous rendrons
de vacances raconte la conquête et
outils de gennady encore rentrer de
vacances
le plu va mieux c'est de vider les
balises avec bérénice tu vas voir ça
fait des mois que je veux partir en
vacances et moi en attendant vous faites
des bâtons des bateaux des barreaux même
pas aux mines à main titus titus est une
bonne nouvelle pour toi
bérénice est de retour je veux
absolument certain je les ai aperçus à
l'autre bout du palais on m'en fait pour
vivre heureux
les vagues ont vu ni témoin envers ces
bateaux il faut que tout soit propre
pour le dos des revenus est bien
titulaire
la voici vérité
[Musique]
beurre mou n'a ni mon titus sur notre
cash
je suis bien content de vous revoir et
nos écrits ou et en banlieue
si le cd da costa rica ah ça fait
plaisir de rentrer chez soi même si
c'est chez le grand jacques à toute
épreuve donne en place est donc remis ça
me sens bien remplie timbres ou
chocolats depositary synaris qui dit
rapporter des sous merdes et que tu me
demande où j'ai reçu tout ça voilà
encore devoir lui remonte pas au lait de
brebis et j'espère que je chante lui
dire tu de 3 4 6 7 6 et bien ça tout est
là estime oscar
à bientôt nous membres remise je partais
avec une valise de revient de 8 février
m alors je me suis fait faire quelques
nouvelles rames
on va tous les ranger tout permettez
rivalisent donc d'importance je pensais
que tu pourrais emprunter un grand
coffre au grand yaka où ça nous ont pas
non non non non non les coffres de
gragnague avant tout plein et puis ils
ont gardé par ceux ci et c'est là dans
ce beau possible
tu t'es pas gentil de leur part une
bonne idée il ya la noire c'est le vide
mais au vétusté remarque une sert à rien
on va demander la clé amcor il est
rentré de vacances du matin au tube i 3
4 5 6 7 8 parfait parce que l'on n'est
pas obligé maintenant d'un clan quel
plaisir d'amour à boire
le joie à mon jeune ami si tu voyais
tout ce que je rapporte au rang de
merveilles incomplet nos valises au
pleine bourre et des blancs dans
d'autres jeux extraordinaires wall e
vous renvoie souvent à balai dont
l'armoire ses bienfaits tous ces biens
l'armoire vide tu la connais a voulu
prendre la clé est allé ouvrir l'armoire
des merveilles la prends tu verras tu es
tous
je n'attendais tour sensationnel alors
le premier cas il faut pas les mettre
dans l'armoire pourquoi donc tu cette
armoire est pleine de microbes on débute
au haut débit thd dans l'armoire on
avait les mythes
donc ça nous ont tous fait des trous
partout c'est bien connu
bon alors c'est rageant bijoux je sais
ce qu'ils te vantes habile et la petite
merveille à votre place
on dirait demandé un grand coffre aux
grands cabas aux agro chauffe eau sale
bundle je leur ai trahis si ce sera très
pratique et trois décors actifs
je vais demander aux grandes gueules ce
poids et auxonne mythe des armoires et
l'athlète en main l'avoir demandée et
après
et c'est notre histoire raconte moi
quand une fille jenna de scitivaux
marque entend pourtant pousser un arbre
et datum avoir grand-dakar voumard
défaite devant des mots voilà bien un
petit moment un moment
le pauvre gringa qu'un camp iata je fais
toujours la rue où étais tu joues c'est
oui oui approche approche pour le mot
voir de plus près titus comment me
trouvais tu es où vous vous trouvez à
fibre on encore vivre et bien sûr mais
ma tête vais quand même trouvé tu mates
êtes vous prête à tout sauvons des pôles
mais ça je sais mais dis moi tu ne me
trouve pas un peu pâle terrasse est
possible ils m'ont ce monde on ne peut
que vous vous êtes un peu pâle lotus
mais je suis très pâle extrêmement pâles
je n'ai plus d'appétit il me manque
quelque chose
grand gars mais vous manque le
grand-père des promenades de marbre au
qu'il était intelligent mais c'est ça il
me faut des arbres grand vabre
bon alors titus tu vas me fait rire
jardin avec de grands arbres et je vais
me promener dans trois minutes allaient
pas vite et de vendre dans trois nuls
vous tous qu'en cas non il ne donnerait
un bonhomme je n'aime pas une petite
graine de radis et il veut des grandes
orgues bon show dhabi auront toutefois
de grands marmont le renouveau de notre
tient parole
alors si tous tu te raconte des
histoires le fou en attendant le temps
vous ne pouvez pas comprendre mercure
comprend tout voiture elle c'est tout le
grand macabre de grands gardois dans
trois minutes telle folie on c'est à
busan
veux tu que nous lui fabriquions des
arbres instantané vous feriez pas au
maître malka vous va être hamid annonça
la buse
j'avais prévu bon ben je veux qu abbas
acabit 'achat' bas et voilà vous pouvoir
je ne ne faut pas se décourager acabit
accable il voit là encore rappelle non
sans se déplie une feuille d'arbre
je suis en pleine forme je continue
acabit aqaba et voilà
et ça ça pourrait être une grande
famille à tabac le voilà encore à tapas
et voilà djabi à tapas et votre
intérieur cabas des feuilles et des
branches classe de nous dans le monde
entier
les trois minutes sont passées je vais
aller me promener dans mon jardin est
vrai que je suis impatient je vais voir
mes grands arbres mosca voilà voilà
chacun vient avec moi je vais voir mes
arbres mais grande yaka b vous n'avez
pas d'arbre ignora peu pessimiste j'ai
de grands arbres et tu va les voir aller
sur moi
lentement dernière folle merci c'est
fini à mettre maintenant mafia d'amour
c'est la plus belle réalisation de match
je suis à puce
c'est bien fait allez vous reposer
vous l'avez bien mérité brossera j'adore
faire des choses qu'ils sont trop petits
dés fois mosca non
nancy respire le bonheur et je sens que
la chlorophylle est en train de s'ouvrir
l'appétit de titus je suis très content
tu as tu un bon petit niort
tu m'as fait plaisir je vais te
récompenser mostar épingle lui de
médailles et un bracelet de ma part tu
croyais ak je te dis qu'en de tout
montre où l'apport au parc du mérite
agricole de schémas tirs soyons vu senna
quand il a mérité de l'emporter
il me donnera peut-être un croissant et
après après c'est une autre histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoutez moi c'est une météo peu de gêne
à dire un ce que tu aimes le furent
prises en vue des rhinites mon art est
une rolls à la guérite elle encore sorti
seul faut se rattraper
je voulais lui montrer les ombres du
grand yaka pouvait l'attendre
où est-elle allée au désert comme chez
ma cuisine de campagne
il faut que je m'en s'ils s'investissent
lui faire une surprise à bord et 1100
les bras d'un grand gré au muret coucou
tvinci t on chez toi qui mois l'a vu
même voulu forcer sans permission et
j'ai bien fait j'ai fait une découverte
extraordinaire on pourra découvrir lors
à tu crois gd je vais te faire une
surprise moi je vous prie pour toi la
mienne d'abba 7 qu'est ce qu'ils y aient
été me suis prêt nous donne moi la main
je suis dans le mois
où allons-nous bien il ne pose pas de
questions tu regarderas car nous serons
arrivés
tu as encore loin nous apprécions
mon gâteau autorise à kaunas origines
volonté de lignum tutu
quand on se trompe en ce seul au grand
yaka aux grands records au superbe but
mais non mais non je suis arrivé en
retard et c'est formidable
et n'est ce pas quitus aux voix la f3000
table sans vous un moment donné vous ne
sais vous j'ai été très bien et très
courageux si tu l'avais vu partir
desquels ma vue
merci beaucoup grand yaka merci non mais
ne va pas par là tu vas encore te faire
capturer par cette grande île merci
beaucoup grandi à marcigny touche tu as
besoin de ma protection
je ne te quitte plus longuement quand
vous y mettiez mais si tu veux te
protège
allez va où tu veux je te tuer ben nous
et par là ça va voir si les armes au sol
sont toujours à leur place
bon alors en avant marche je suis
content si je suis le plus courageux je
suis le plus beau et je suis le plus
courageux et emmène titus au sucre ou
yaka je le déteste je le déteste
ils vont voir les arbres c'était ma
surprise pour tutu ou ce grand gars je
le déteste
énormes avoirs qui le plus courageux des
deux voilà pourtant d'arriver et tu vois
l'attitude et je te tiennent toujours et
tu vraiment très courageux n'est ce pas
que le prêtre est beaucoup et marroux et
m'encouragent et me demande où vous
trouvez tout son courage est hélas ma
main à la souris à la souris je sais
quoi
assez pour l'artiste qu'est ce que tu
dit ça roddick en font une ville où il
fait opérer mais c'est quelqu'un de même
et après après c'est une autre histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ajoute moi quand tu étais une fille
jenna dire une histoire incroyable une
image de la tête amis d'att mais m celle
de la popul est bientôt fini encore deux
minutes et margot vais terminer quel art
et il fait beau possible de commencer ma
portée à 7 heures gardien dominic au
travail ans de conflit elle est arrêtée
c'est bien ça elle dort l'apartheid dont
elle a réveillé la mettre à l'heure je
suis chez moi à chiffrer c'est peut être
l'heure de mon repas mosca vous avez la
grande yaka
ce que j'ai fait alors qu'elle aurait
tier 1 est en gros y'a que je vais
consulter la peau dure
c'est ça peut vite et reviens rapidement
cette pendule et à l'autre extrémité du
palais parce que le grand yaka ne
supporte pas sauté du tac
[Musique]
la porte est ouverte
à quelle négligence le moindre courant
d'air peu enrhumé suffrages il une
pendule
peillon quelle heure est il mais qui a
parlé je ne rêve pas la pro du parc
la pendule a parlé auquel faire alors
mosca quelle heure est il il est 7h30
quand y'a qu'a tu en es bien sûr quand
il ya quinze jours suis certain c'est
elle même qui me l'a dit commun l'a pas
dit a parlé elle m'a parlé comme je vous
parle homo ce cas mais tu es malade
le beau nul ne parle pas ça dit pas ça
dit pas encore yaka si la première fois
mais elle apparaît au je veux le dire
mais je veux que tu n'as mais moi je
vais ici des goyas cas je vais il a
poussé jusqu ici un destin ou voit le
double non au moins moi
[Musique]
on travaille bien on se très pratique
sur cette pendule parlant d' excellente
idée
c'est très moderne c'est bien fait je
rêve est ce possible
michel marsh et le marche alors c'était
pas nul quant à kad et le march et mais
j'espère bien qu'elle marche et le
marché depuis des césar c'est son
travail alors je veux la voir les impôts
si la raf la fois si grand drap grande
yaka et aux masques à moscou mais je
rêve je le veux marcher jusqu'à le
domaine de koulouba
ouvrez vos yeux voila voila grande yaka
[Musique]
jalouse voilà elle est ouverte on chez
toi tu touches à lormont pas tenté
femmes ont su le droit donc on a beau
leur alors au curieuse façon assez titi
sera qu il est astucieux il a fait
marcher la pendule et jusqu'ici remet ça
alors c'est très adroit mais ouais j'ai
treize mois
titus tum amendola la fin d'une comme ça
chaque fois que je te demanderai le riz
et moi l'a fait convaincant revue devenu
le lion pendule et après après c'est
notre histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ecoutez-moi construit qui ont pillé tout
jeune à qui michael faisait souvent des
surprises
il avait toujours des choses
extraordinaires dans combettes vous tous
sur tous attendus et convoite itunes à
mon président à prendre la relève ou
parent et pape sy touche mon garçon j'ai
besoin de toujours bon cette fois mais
pas ma vie quelle part des choses cette
loi mais il faut faire quelque chose
la dombes au bec tour et dont je
dépassement à support semble ouvert en
grand s'il vous plaît maman crocodile de
passage chez moi on s'est fait un nom et
elle pas attention ça recommence je
record dépasse mon vrai talent menad
attentes ou non et à toute la famille
parent d'élève je veux sans vie sera la
leur au mercy beau garçon vêtu
l'accompagnait je vais voir le grand
yaka a pas finis a rendez vous avec
benny alors jeunes racistes que toi
amuse toi bien
si vous avez encore des pansements
premier mémoire d'art en vrac pas or moi
les ouvriers haye où la parole est
conquis et ben nature n'a laissé d'antan
naissance à l'âge allons là c'est moi
aller jouer ailleurs
et me ramenez pas sinon je n'en ai très
en colère ali disparités je vais voir
des mises je n'ai pas besoin de vous
voulez vous laisser aller d'un homme est
ou non en bon meneur vers la fin des
travaux mais trempé dont
[Musique]
et hélas bien femme vient va vous
libérer après mon rendez-vous avec
bérénice chez blizzard c'est à shalit
fait dangereux
que signifie cette construction au beau
milieu du passage si le grand yaka viens
par ici
il ne pourra voir passer il faut
déplacer tout ça jusqu'ici et bien mhk
au travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la région on se couvre aussi que c'est
pour toi béléné anti-tht estime ambiante
qu'est ce que c'est au tour du groupe
profonde mais c'est moi qui les paie non
pas psy des castagnettes ans j'adore les
castagnettes tu permets que je
t'embrasse
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe on vous balance de malheurs
d'un profond merlus savons nous passer
devant nous mais nos titus je sais
comment on dresse une pince à l'aise
gardes mobiles en buggy l'incroyable pas
et bien pourtant pas fait pas c'est
comme ça et après après il fut contré
toi
[Applaudissements]
oh
écoute moi quand tu étais au pdg m'a dit
tu sais que pour faire pousser les
arbres ou les affronter
alors voila voila mon chien comment
trouves-tu mam ignoriez crayats cas chez
qu'un bâtiment admirable j'ai décidé de
prendre un bain et il paraît que ça fait
du bien
ah oui alors il faut remplir la
baignoire
c'est ça le bonheur que tu y mets de
l'eau je vais voir mes arte viendra me
me prévenir qu'un bel sera pris et tigre
aya kanno demande qu'aucune dont il avec
des femmes superbes et pays plus de
feuilles au mes charmes mais nous sommes
passés mes arbres ils sont toujours en
grand et encore tu te moques de moi
titus mais avant des fayots magnifique
et ça ce sont des déportés maintenant
non alors vous serez fier de mes hommes
regardent a juste pas elles sont parties
franck desrumeaux titude je te préviens
tu auras 12,5 ou de passants si dans six
minutes mais avant non pas de feuilles
de peinture ayaka et paraît bon très
bien que je vais pas nommer et tu as
compris titus et des feuilles sur les
arbres si noble de cinq coups de bâton
quel métier de temps ou de battant cet
imposant de son jeu de baston font
exactement deux fois sans coup de bâton
c'est bien vous qui écrivez tout pour
vous me dire pourquoi les bardeaux coup
d'oeil à jacques le foll à 20 soit halal
sont artistes des haltères un ailleurs
c'est très simple je vais tout donner à
tulle ont établi à 4 bat et voilà à un
tuyau d'arrosage
alors fais ci prend ce qu'il te faut
vous pour cette longueur suffira alors
je cours vite maître malka accusés c'est
bien mais yves baudelot
alors pour ça ne compte pas sur quoi je
te donne la note with you après j'aurai
toi de trouver de loups nous voilà bien
avancés
mais je pense il ya deux lancers louvre
on reviendra plus bas programme un aa
paris-xi grand yaka
si vous voulez bien vous ai déjà billets
tiennent comme un saut par mes
chaussures et si le praia cave bien
soulever le pied gauche je remercie le
droit à présent chez je remercie ceux ci
comptent altissimo ce cas c'était je
vais prendre mon premier vrai ça fait
drôle et pendant ce temps on passe dans
mon tuyau et va donner à boire à mes
arbres et haies les five o robben yves
en pis les plants d'arbres à touvre
qu'elles sont belles elles dont but ou
plomb du zinc du goya cas revêt annoncé
que les pales sont revenus ils vont bien
faire disparaître le tuyau avant la
limite du grand yaka tu es jeune et
incapable mosca tu as laissé partir
l'eau de ma baignoire et à présent je
vais faire donner de simple coup de
peinture et titus en engrangeant qu'à
regarder d'abord move arbres voilà me
louer comme le voilà mes jolies feuilles
enfin quelque chose qui me fait plaisir
at it is te félicite voyez grand gaza
les feuilles sont là raconte moi comment
tu as fait hossa grand n'a qu'à vous
avez c'est comme les problèmes de vases
communicants
c'est très difficile à expliquer le
principal est d'avoir un bon tuyau et
après après
et d'une autre ils doivent
[Applaudissements]
photos - cacao thé et de riz nagui à
vous la magie les 3000 clients et tout
va voir tout ce qui est arrivé ce que
j'ai suivi mes visites robot moitié
lundi le plus beau regret n'y a qu'à du
monde quoi quelques n'est pas de cet
avis qu est ce que je suis beau alors
têtu ce ne te gêne pas le témoin la
vérité commun mais trouve utile et vous
met à l'heure des réseaux gang là et
c'est bien deux bouts de troncs up
pourrait freux tu as dit affreux et jure
on veut y a qu'à trier et ceci cela a
sapé le intermédiaire être 780 je cite
un moment il est un peu votre grand
gâteau apple charmante soirée en
perspective
il faut que l'on sorte de cette cave
vous avez envoyé une lettre à melchior
métro melchior wathelet venaient à mon
secours signé tous voilà une lettre qui
va me sauver sa vie va portefaix
plaindra malveillants qui quittera bien
compris cette lettre et pour malka qui
fit le moral melki en ramenant partir de
là titus je me suis beaucoup de pub
aujourd'hui les punis et lâche c'est
regrettable
las ce blanc trust toi qu'est-ce que si
une lettre et des taux de la moit ceci
une lettre à lire c'est bien petit grain
de mousse 15e la lire
voilà voisin quand y'a qu'à nous allons
dire la lettre et voyant par exemple
alors moi ce que tu sais lire mon nom je
n'ai pas regardé par péché c'est
illisible et seul melchior pourra
l'aider chiffre est meilleur mais le
coeur tu vas me dire si tous les deux
donné lui mosca cherves être un pur
hasard j'en suis refais lot choyée par
le temps c'est une lettre de titus qui
vous appelle à son secours
je vais comprise matelas dans mon bac je
vais la transforma je voulais confie
alors mais le tueur s'étalait testing ni
viable nous allons le savoir atteint +
accueil bla voilà lycée je vous prie en
soignant à votre dixie en chaleur grâce
à sa merci de m'avoir fait offert mais
tomba cage et c'est bien et c'est très
bien
je suis rasé heureux je mets un bus à
pau tout et d'assyrie race trait le plus
longtemps possible
ça c'est bien de tous ou à ses titus qui
a écrit ça ils s'amusent les sièges à
menominee nominale jamais je ne fais pas
et je ne veux pas mon coeur ne vient pas
manteaux courts pour vous que ce qui lui
est bien remis ma lettre
je suis tellement mal dans ce cadre et
us et punis et je ne veux pas qu'ils
s'amusent dans ses cages
je veux la lui confisquer aller ceci
vient avec moi qui me voilà beau monde
chez moi qui commande ici cela s'est si
oui laquelle
titus alexandre bouffard vous nous ferez
rapide les emporter la cache la
confisque à a tué privé de cage
je suis bien content avec des copains
vous ne comprend rien il est vous
il est dangereux de bonhomme avoue à
plat et va bien se passer
oui si la lettre que bell qui aura lieu
au crack
je reçois un seul os au madame une
famille quand c'est bon la liberté et
après a fait est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]